Over the course of six
weeks in the summer of 2014,
Market Basket employees,
joined by their customers,
protested against the
firing of their beloved CEO.
They risked their jobs,
their livelihoods,
and they brought the
business to a halt.
At a time when we see so much
division between the CEOs who
represent the top 1% and
the workers, who represent
by the bottom 99%, this
level of support for a CEO
got the attention of
the entire country.
Arthur Demoulas, he
stands for valuing people.
He always says we are in
the people business first,
grocery business second.
And when the
ownership changed, you
started asking the
questions, what's going
to happen with our benefits?
What's going to
happen with our pay?
And when you start taking
away that factor of focusing
on people, the entire business
model starts to fall apart.
The workers were
fighting for a business
model that works for everyone--
for them, for their customers,
and for their shareholders.
We saw a number of
critical business lessons
that emerged from Market Basket.
Let me share with you
three related lessons.
The first lesson is around
creating customer and employee
loyalty in a pretty
unlikely setting.
Local supermarkets
are not necessarily
known for treating their
employees or customers well.
They are known for offering
bad jobs with poverty level
wages, unpredictable schedules,
and very few opportunities
for success and growth.
They're also known to
frustrate their customers.
The Market Basket
case shows us that it
doesn't have to be that way.
Here's a company that really
puts a focus on building
those relationships.
It's easy to say treat
a customer as you
would like to be treated.
It's a lot different
to say that you
would treat your
customers the way
you would treat your
family or your friends.
Because there's a
lot a loyalty there.
The second lesson that
emerged from Market Basket
is the importance of
employees and what
they do for efficient,
low-cost operations.
You see, Market Basket pays
its employees decent wages.
It offers them
generous benefits.
It treats them with
respect and dignity.
Market Basket designs
the jobs in a way
that allows their employees
to be more motivated, that
allows them to be
more productive,
and that allows them
to contribute more
to the success of their company.
It's not just working
for the paycheck;
it's working for what you're
getting out of the job.
Getting that feeling that you're
providing something of value
that they appreciate, and
appreciating somebody else.
That's a huge motivator for me.
And carrying that through
the company to bring
value to the company.
Who wouldn't want
to work for that?
If you go to a
Market Basket store,
you're going to see a
lot of employees around.
A lot more than what you
see at a local supermarket .
Why is that?
Well, Market Basket does
that so that its employees
can do their jobs
without making errors.
So that they're not rushed.
So that they can treat
their customers well,
help them out when necessary.
So that they have
enough time to engage
in continuous improvement,
come up with suggestions
to reduce cost and increase
customer service and sales.
Appropriate staffing levels
is just one of the job design
decisions that
motivate employees,
make their jobs better,
so make them happier,
that lead to happy
customers, because they
receive better service.
And that also lead
to happier investors
because now the costs are
lower, sales are higher,
and profits are higher.
And that brings me to the
third decision related
to Market Basket, which is
even in a low-cost supermarket
setting, it is not only
possible but highly profitable
to create a business
model that creates
value for customers, employees,
and investors at the same time.
There's a lot of
focus on people.
You have 8 owners
and shareholders,
and then you have
25,000 employees.
And then you have
the further impact
of vendors and customers.
That's a huge base.
Now you're talking
millions of people.
And here's a company that really
puts a focus on everyone who's
involved with our company.
Now, you might wonder, is
Market Basket an exception?
Is it unique?
Well, certainly, what
Market Basket employees
did was pretty extraordinary.
But Market Basket's business
model is hardly special.
In fact, in my
own research, I've
studied four other
low-cost retailers
that do exactly the
same, ranging from Costco
to QuikTrip, a convenience store
chain with gas stations, that
has been in Fortune's
100 best companies
to work for 12 years
in a row and that
is extremely profitable.
If good jobs are possible
at a setting like QuikTrip,
they are possible everywhere.
We just need more companies to
follow the good job strategy.
And everyone can do their part.
You are customers.
You can walk with your feet.
You can decide the shop or dine
at places that offer good jobs.
For those of you who
are employees, managers,
or even investors
in organizations,
then you could be advocates
for a good job strategy.
Finally, I want to leave
you with one last thought.
At some point in
your career, chances
are you'll be a manager.
You might manage just a few
people or hundreds of people.
Remember this, the types
of decisions that you make
are not just business decisions.
They affect the lives of people,
so make those decisions wisely.